[Music]
i think it's safe to say it is
officially festival time uh i don't know
about you but i was not expecting the
onslaught
of
of lineups to come out in the um you
know the last couple of weeks where you
know we kind of thought it would be uh a
light time barry we thought that we'd
have a little bit of a break
no no no no lineup after lineup after
lineup after lineup uh comes out even
ones that we were not expecting
whatsoever barry corder brad steiner
it's the what podcast uh i don't know
where lord taco is today is everybody
okay is lord taco's safe is he healthy
did i kill him when he came to new
orleans it's a travel day i guess right
i hope i didn't kill him i uh when he
came to town i decided to make sure that
i could
really up his pbr game and take him to
every dive bar in the city we might have
hit
20 different dive bars wow
and and he'll tell you that a a pbr and
one tastes different than a pbr and
another well they all they all got four
stars on untapped every one of them got
four stars
he had a mirador of different pbrs he
had a pbr a draft he had a 16 ounce he
had a 12 ounce you know i think that the
man really lived his best pbr life over
the weekend yeah he went to new orleans
went crazy uh-huh he did he went a
little nutty and hey barry
you're next where you been i know you've
been you know it's time to leave the
state
this book i know this century
i'm gonna have to do it come see brad
hey how are uh how you feeling
everything good anybody uh get hit with
the coven yeah yeah had a couple family
members
little ones
yeah
you know i don't know what it is but
every single person i know has had it
literally every single person and to the
point where like we haven't still to
this day we have not yet
um gotten any sort of not even the
sniffles so i i say this all the time i
feel like i'm in a circular firing squad
and i'm like the matrix just dodging
you know bullets like i'm some sort of
you know rubber man or something it was
i don't know how in the world we've
survived it but um
yeah the week of christmas
i mean the person it was like five days
in a row where the person that we hung
out the night before the next morning
test positive oh you're a carrier
it might be us we might be patient zero
i think we found that
i mean i it was like
wake up in the morning who we got uh all
right and then the five day countdown
starts with us you know like all right
well let's see if we're screwed in the
next five days and still nothing still
nothing we're pretty close to the same
we
kelly and i are both convinced we had it
way back two years ago at the you know
this is a different stream
i know somebody's had all three strains
oh wow yeah since then we haven't had i
mean little sniffles here and there
we've had
like my mother you know had a flu kept
testing negative wow yeah i had a bunch
of that and i'm guessing she's older
than you she's a little bit older okay
she's 80 she's almost 80 yes she's 88.
kidding yeah and she did all right it's
scary and then the little ones like i
said the little ones have it
have had it yeah my nephew had it for a
couple of days
it yeah it's i i don't i don't i mean
good for you getting good for you
staying uh staying healthy because i
can't have anything happen to my barry
well that's why your barry doesn't leave
the state but bless the house
let's let's be honest your state is
probably doing his worst as any of them
that's exactly right
it's amazing i do love this idea that
you now are blaming coven for not
leaving the house
and you have never
left the house or state before you know
before before that having children was a
great excuse because then you know if
you didn't want to go somewhere ah i
wish i could
or now it's somewhere and you want to
leave early got it now it's baby now i
think i was exposed i think i was
exposed i uh can't i can't do anything
today
yeah we're not doing it
but you'll see me out somewhere else but
not your thing sure but as long as it's
before 3 p.m
in bed by 3 p.m yeah you got to get the
early birds back get the early bird
buffet turn on the dehumidifier and then
you're curled up under a blanket by 3
30. that's right
so oh hey mom oh hey hey girl hey uh so
let's go through some of these uh
lineups that
i'm not kidding i was not expecting uh
so many to come at once i think the the
one that was the easiest one to sort of
cross off the list was coachella because
they should have come out before um
before bonnaroo you know they had so
much drama surrounding coachella they
lose you know they kick travis scott off
they lose rage against the machine
they've got a you know another headliner
they've got to fill so
you know for all intense purposes i
think coachella did incredible i said
this on twitter if you can just pull
harry styles out of your back pocket you
know that's insane yeah i mean at the
last second
harry styles comes to save the day no
you may not be a pop fan and that's fine
but harry styles is a legit a artist the
dude is incredible um and even though
you might hate one direction and you
have every right to
harry styles is a real thing he's a real
massive um artist and frankly
um but either way
billy eilish kanye
um uh harry styles as a top line it may
not be for you but that is a massive
massive get for an operation that was i
think really in
at there was going to be a point where
if they didn't fill that slot they were
going to move swedish house mafia up in
the return of uh you know those guys and
the reunion there
you know you can say that you know
losing rage
doesn't give coachella sort of the
lack of a better term the balls that
coachella usually has but
look in a world where the festival
festivals are they don't know who they
can get how they can get them for
coachella to pick up harry styles and
billy eilish and kanye on a whim
seemingly out of nowhere
yeah that's incredible work
i think
uh several things i mean you correct me
if i'm wrong we've said it before um
you've said it
before probably first years ago that
they're announcing earlier and earlier
because they're all competing for the
same tickets
so you know you don't want to
have a bonnaroo announced and then you
sit on it for weeks and weeks while
people decide whether or they're going
to spend their money
number one number two
uh from what i'm hearing
like even our festival here got put
together really quickly
um
you it's funny it's either really
quickly or really slowly because it's
taken three years in the making right
but uh
most of them
had lineups for last year blew those all
up and started fresh but from what i'm
hearing is
once it got going it all happened pretty
quickly um
and i think that's because
the acts
are anxious to get back out and the
festivals obviously are just to
get it done so you've had this kind of
environment where everybody's ready to
go to work
i did hear i did hear really early on
and this was probably back in october or
september that the bonnaroo lineup was
going to be like 75 the same lineup as
2021 and nothing seemed right about that
and i'm glad um i'm glad
you know i i sort of held back from
going with that but they um i think that
that was what they tried if i could put
the pieces together from what he told me
like i think that that's where they were
working from they were working from a
you know a template that they had
already created and
you're right they just eventually
yeah
fall apart because you know you look at
look at uh you know uh
our girl lizzo she's the reason why
she's not doing it different album cycle
she the album's not done yet she doesn't
have a single that really is just sort
of mediocre at top 40 radio did okay at
urban radio um just didn't have the the
the gas for it and um
you know
the realization that this is a really
hard thing to do
i give banaru a little bit of leeway but
also
i don't know how and we'll talk about
this at the end but i don't know how you
can
love the bonnaroo lineup when
there's one two three four five six
seven festivals that all announced after
it and seemingly
you know had a little bit more weight to
it
yeah and it's not fair as you you said
over the weekend as we were chatting
back and forth but that jazz fest line
up i mean it it literally looks like you
just went to the live nation website and
hit their roster
i'll take all of these things all of
them thank you very much
who's missing um and that that's not not
fair because they always do an amazing
job but um
yeah there's
it's hard to read them uh one thing that
it seems to me is that the festivals
whether it's accidental or on purpose
have
are tightening their uh brand
if you will they're focusing on
who they're going after um yeah i mean
it's a good point and i think that that
brings up the first festival that i want
to talk about that was um just
completely out of left field and i
didn't see it coming and nobody
whatever
when we were young
is the biggest music festival reaction i
have ever seen
this thing has exploded it took over the
internet it took over conversation and
and i
i think the damn thing sold out in like
two hours it was it was such a big
success they added a second day of all
the same artists
look you may not be a 35 year old emo
girl um but a lot of i know a lot of
them
i know a lot of them this lineup is so
unbelievably one lane and
it
got every one of those bands in the same
lane
another one and another one and another
one another one and it's all on the same
day
all in the same day
my chemical romance paramore taking back
sunday bring me the horizon boys like
girls avril lavigne jimmy world
um
i i just i
none of these bands do anything for me
but boy
there is a massive audience for this and
it makes me wonder i had this
conversation with someone in the
industry the other day barry
it makes me wonder if this resets the
way
that these festivals start getting
programmed shakiness does an incredible
job of this of finding one lane and
staying right there over and over and
over and maximizing the people that they
can get uh in you know in that space in
sort of the indie rock space
this when we were young thing
i could see this thing turning into
warp tour 2022
take these bands and just take them
around the country and do a one-day
two-day festival around the country and
live nation just
can be rolling in money after that yeah
it's
my guess is it's it's all cyclical uh
probably in two three four five years
whatever i i won't i can't put a number
on it but we'll be talking about how
festivals are branched out and realize
they can't stay in one lane anymore
maybe yeah but but it certainly feels
like right now
and
and
i told you i want to mention it
our
riverbend festival which has gotten not
much love on this podcast over the years
tried to be in all thanks to all
all fans festival for many many years
and did it
somewhat successfully depending on how
you wanted to find their mission but
they've got a up
they've redone reset and they've got a
lineup that to me is
looks a whole lot like some of these
others it's very specific
it does away with
the old model
and
it's interesting to hear the fans
reaction people like you and me seem to
really like it the uh
the fans that wanted to get their free
wristband and go down there for nothing
and just hang out hate it because they
don't know anybody on it
so
well to be fair to to add some context
that festival that you're talking about
in chattanooga was historically a
festival where old people brought lawn
chairs right so if you just draw just
put it in your mind an old person
bringing their lawn chair and sitting it
down and staying there for the next 12
hours
that they know of and then think about
the hardest that they would be watching
and then that was the festival and then
you know they were the last holdout
other than like the jazz fest and the
coachellas of doing a two-week non-stop
thing and and then not only was it you
know two weeks of like really iffy
artists but there's always the gutter
salesman walking up and down selling
gutters
and in
in any festival in the world do you have
something like this so yeah you know it
needed a lot of um they needed a wrinkle
iron out some of the wrinkles of this
thing so and it sounds like they have
and the lineup is is very nice and it's
the first time that we saw kg elephant's
name on a festival line which is
surprising considering i was told that
because they've got an album out and
they'll have you know
this is their you know this is their
main cycle this year they uh
they're gonna be doing all the festivals
what i was told well i've seen how many
festival lineups and the only one i can
find is is riverbend so maybe it's um
maybe we're still you know a year off
off from seeing kg elephant on every
festival lineup but
brothers was yeah caged the elephant
jason is bull l king government mule
grace potter those are the top lines
jenny lewis moon taxi
and tonya tucker uh and i'm tol that one
surprised me and i'm told the reason
she's on there is it's the 50th
anniversary of delta dawn and the label
is going to be doing some uh
some stuff so i like tanya tucker i
don't think she's a fighter man
i know i know uh you know this is not
for everybody there's something about
like 60s country artists that
if you've listened to this show long
enough i think that barry and i could
nerd out about 60s countries artists
absolutely
more than anything all right absolutely
um
so but anyway i just want to bring that
up but
it's an example of and i've heard people
complaining over the weekend that it's
too narrow
you know what i mean they local they
like they like that broad and i think
that's where we're seeing
festivals going
picking lanes and sticking with them and
we'll see how long that ride you know
how long it goes
yeah you know it does
unless you've got some amazing
backing unless you've got major
money with
excuse me
the ability to draw from a huge swath of
people um you know i i do wonder
how much time bonnaroo especially a
bonnaroo like festival has in it just
continually draw continually throwing
out a why casting a wide net and trying
to get as much diversity as they can
although that's what we're wanting
that's the thing that we we
beg for bottaru to do
and we i hope to god they keep doing it
i wonder how long they can continue
doing that
in an era where it feels like
these
festivals are getting
much more focused and much more
um
coned if you will i mean they're they're
all putting their their eggs into a
basket of
you know
emo
emo art music
like
the the i still can't get over
how much reaction
this
when we were young festival
got i i can't believe it because
most of the time you see these things
coming you know they give you some
it's a brand new festival there were
people on the internet who didn't even
think this was real it was like the day
that remember the day that we were
talking about a couple maybe a year ago
and we were like
why don't you just say that you booked
everybody right and
you're gonna cancel anyway so just say
you booked everybody we got the reunion
led zeppelin we've got uh you know
yeah that's funny the rolling stones
we've got you too
who cares
you say that you have everybody what's
it matter yeah they legitimately bought
they booked everybody
they booked every single person in that
genre and people honestly thought it
wasn't real
there were people on the on the
uh especially twitter the twitterverse
exploded thinking that this was some
sort of long con from live nation who
was just trying to grab some money
to make up for their lost revenue for
the last year and a half
and then they turn around and they sell
out the first day at a whole second day
which again talk about an
unbelievable how is it that in this
world
you take i don't know what is what's
your 45 bands on this thing and they
call every one of them up and say ah by
the way yeah we won't just stick around
one more day i need you to stick around
uh that was that was pre-planned they
had two days set the whole time they
wanted to see how the first date went
and then
if it went well and the reaction was
what they thought it would be let's add
a second day um
live
live nation absolutely hit a home run
with this thing i i i
just don't want to stop thinking about
it that's weird to say
it's just a feat it's a feat that
doesn't necessarily happen very often
yeah i agree
i agree
especially in a world where everybody
complains about everything
you can't find somebody to not [ __ ]
about insert line up here this was the
first time i felt
that the reaction was so overwhelmingly
positive
um i don't know
i don't like any spans but i'm really
glad that it's around i'm really glad
it's here
that's
there's several of these
lists like that and you you said it last
time we were on maybe we're getting old
i don't know um but i also know that not
everything is designed for me
yeah and i'm okay with that that's okay
yeah yeah and and um
the band let's put it this way the
festivals that are for you jazz fest
i'm i can't tell you how excited i am
about jazz fest i've never been and i've
been i've been
i don't know if i told this story on the
air but i've literally we we moved to a
house
that is four blocks from jazz fest so
that we could walk to jazz fest
and
and the fact that we still haven't been
a jazz fest
is so irritating um you know you're
incredible
if there's anybody left on your bucket
list
after that i i don't you're being very
picky
yeah well they're dead
i like your boy lionel richie's back
um foo fighters seemingly get to you
know make their return to new orleans
they had another show that was canceled
um
you know they were supposed to be at the
whenever that festival was the who
um now barry you have to explain to me
the who to me is a lot like you know you
two in that i know that they exist
and i don't know if i like them or not
you will
you will um
it'll be one of those where it's 90
minutes of
just song after song that you know yeah
that you not only know but you know grew
up with and probably can sing every word
whether you know it or not yeah
yeah they are kind of an unusual
they're
they rank in there with the stones and
the beatles and um
yeah but they never get they never get
the heat they never get stones
yeah they never get never quite get
there and they had some some weird years
where they
some internal stuff but uh and they you
know
keith moon dying
hurt them
but they're still very good
and that would be on my list but that
top line
yeah i can't catch my breath
barry i need you to catch a breath i
can't have i can't have dad
be sick catch a breath yeah no that's an
amazing lineup but
it looks like live nation's uh roster
yeah i mean it did really well because
it hits it hits a little bit for
everybody and then you get to you know
ceelo and blow and it's just this
beautiful
celebration of new orleans
music and um
i love look
there's this there's a weird thing about
this city
the people here
really
care about new orleans music more than
they care about the top four lines you
know the the reason why
jazz fest is so beloved is because you
can walk in
at a really cheap price at 10 o'clock in
the morning and spend all day just
listening to all your favorite local
artists
and um it's just like it's like nowhere
else in the world that i've i've seen i
almost care more about seeing nicholas
payton than i do foo fighters
i care so much about seeing karmic
ruffins
at jazz fest
now i will say the the one
thing that i haven't seen in this lineup
and it's sort of confusing and maybe
there's a reason for it um
every sunday the final jazz fest sunday
there's a huge neville brothers
show they're always the closer for jazz
fest and i see no neville brothers on
this oh yeah it's right there i'm
looking right at it where right right in
the middle tribute to art and charles
neville with the funky meters and the
neville brothers band yeah i don't see
it right in the middle
right above warren treaty
unless i'm no i'm looking
and i think cyril yeah cyril neville's
on the list
where are you seeing that
right in the middle
oh yeah there it is
yeah and like betty lavette give me a
break
um yeah i could go this entire
the the last 35 lines i could
yeah yeah that would be strong just give
me the
give me all of that
rebirth i've become really good friends
with those guys i
give me a break yeah even the tribute
stuff looks i mean the tribute to dr
john the tribute to bessie smith
i have always heard that most of the
locals end up in bars like you were
talking about rather than
you know at the the big stages yeah and
then there's all the activity around the
city of you know who pops in where you
know there is always there's always this
idea that
i think that whenever i see foo fighters
on the lineup of any lineup that i find
i start looking around the city wherever
they're playing and seeing where dave
might pop up and do something else sure
and i you know dave loved this city so
much so there's no chance he doesn't do
something with prez hall
wandering around the corner i just
there's no possible way yeah dave's
going to be everywhere in the city and
we're going to have one of these moments
where every time i open up instagram i'm
going to see somebody taking a selfie
with dave grohl um
that's the most exciting part of how i'm
excited about feeling the buzz inside
the the city for so who's going to leave
away from willie nelson's bus or he
won't make it anywhere
um the other one that came out was a
very very strong showing from boston
calling which
underground this festival keeps hitting
home run after home run every year
every year i always say to myself man
that boss and calling lineups are really
good
and it's like they've done this without
anybody noticing and i know they've got
they they always sell out they always do
well but they're like
they're like shaky knees of the
northeast
and neither one of them gets the credit
that they deserve because
boston callings lineup
barry
is better than bonnaroo's yeah it's good
it's really good incredible
metallica the strokes
foods rufus to soul run the jewels
weezer glass animals modest i'm not i
can't even read all of these i mean this
is it's just
major artist after major artist and um
they they absolutely killed it
i'd like to see uh did we decide is it
haim or hayam i've always said hi
yeah
i'd like to see them again
that's another one of the bonnaroo shows
that i saw and i really liked but i
didn't know a lot about them yeah that i
wish i had a do-over just because i've
become a huge fan
yeah i um and i if somebody has actually
been to boston calling please uh email
us or tweet us the what underscore
podcast uh i actually don't know
anything about the the grounds i don't
know
um what the festival is like but you
know
they get my attention every year and
then i feel like nobody really talks
about them
you know they just secretly
just keep
hammering out great lineup after great
lineups so um yeah that's a good one i
put them up with shaky knees and what
shakiness did this year with green bay
nine inch nails my morning jacket and
then the rest of the festival and how
full it is after that uh is is terrific
and i would argue barry
i would argue that aside from boston
calling which is just too much into my
like everything in my wheelhouse is is
there
i think shakiness has the best lineup of
the entire group like if i go for me if
i go jazz fest shakiness primavera sound
la when we were young boston calling
coachella bonnaroo hang out i guess he'd
throw in there too
shaky knees i think i think shakiness
has got it yep i don't disagree i don't
disagree
um
yeah bonnaroo's down at the at the
bottom for me this year well has that
changed since you saw the lineup the
first night you know you came out of it
much more positive you and taco much
more positive than i did
do you think that your opinion at
sitting on it two weeks has changed it
has changed because of the others
there are still people on it that i will
see
and and
but top to bottom it's not as strong as
the others
for me
and again i i keep hearing you know the
edm crowd is thrilled
and there's a lot of acts that
that people are excited to see it just
doesn't it's not me
yeah
and again that's you know
i hear you every year can't be
yeah i hear you
i keep going back to bonnaroo even when
taco is here you know taco really likes
the lineup and uh you know so we went
right back through it and you know i
tried to find something
anything on sunday
i got nothing i really got not even
stevie nicks i mean i guess daniel
i guess but like herbie i saw nathaniel
at tippetinas two weeks ago you know i
saw i got stevie nicks coming to to jazz
fest you know there's just nothing there
that is so overwhelmingly
interesting that i gotta i i gotta go
only to bonner it's it's back to the
point that you were making earlier about
the ticket buying public when they have
to make their choice as to exactly what
they want to to put their money behind
you know you're
luckily for bonnaroo they have created
an entire world where
the vibe the feeling everything about
the festival is almost more important
than the lineup itself now some years
that
actually
it turns out to be true and some years
you know they they get you know 35 000
people there but for the most part
they've sort of insulated themselves
from
iffy years
absolutely
absolutely they have uh it goes back to
what we were well i sort of hinted at i
didn't i didn't specifically
but this adaptation this idea of being
around for years you and i have watched
this this whole industry change
for 20 years basically since 2002
and
you know bonnaroo early on especially
still get knocked they still get knocked
for not being what they started out as
and as you and i have been told many
times on this show they never were going
to be a hippie fest forever
you know the idea was always to adapt
and develop the vip experiences and the
camping experiences because they realize
it's a camping experience you know it's
not a city fest it's different
and so they've really worked on
on those
now
i guess one could argue
did they do it at the
at the expense of the lineup this year
or is this you know just not for you and
me
lineup i'm probably gonna we'll see with
the ticket sales
but they man they're competing with some
pretty strong lineups out there yeah
that's right and and
you know what you just nailed it i'm so
interested to see how they compete
i'm so interested how they end up
with all of these
festivals
where they end up when with ticket sales
and i think that the the kicker for me
is i feel like i'm going to reserve
judgment until
they start rolling out the plan for the
plazas you know those plazas really do
end up being
well that doesn't really help a ticket
buyer though the ticket buyer needs to
make a decision now the ticket buyer
needs to know you know where they're
spending their vacation time and their
their their you know their money
so
waiting for a plaza announcement is
is going to be difficult for a general
ticket buyer but for me
when
they start rolling out their plan for
the plazas that then changes a little
bit of the way that i view the festival
i think i hope i hope because there is
opportunities for them to really um do
the plaza stuff really i mean look at
what they had paramore they had hayley
williams out there for the better part
of you know two years and now paramore
is the top line of when we were young
yeah
yeah we don't know what they have
planned we haven't really talked to
anybody uh
with inside knowledge
in the three years to know what what
they've done you know we never got to
see it last year
all kinds of speculation and thoughts
and wonder
um
but and
by the way they're very good
we both know they're very good at
creating these experiences it's never
not great you know there's a reason ken
weinstein weinstein came up with that
that phrase that we've adopted
is every year you know we think oh
they've screwed it up and we get there
and there's something really really cool
um some new thing and
you know so i was excited to see what
those things were going to be and i
still am
the one that the one that we missed was
uh forecastle did you take a look at
what forecastle did this year i did um
they did all right um
you know i think claro is a good poll uh
i love
that team impala is finding themselves
you know doing some sort of festival
dates and you know the tyler the creator
uh booking was you know i think
something that a lot of people in the
coachella in the bonnaroo world wanted
to come back i think they did fine
the i think there's only one
how many more festivals are we are we
holding out on at this point firefly is
firefly the only one and then
if and i don't think it's going to but
if
um
you know uh
the new orleans festival here the
halloween weekend comes back i i don't
i don't think i'm missing any others i'm
wondering if there's any other like
major festival that we're still holding
out for
um other than firefly i don't think that
there is somebody can correct me though
i'm looking at it yeah that's it's good
and i like that festival you know you
and i went you've been a couple of times
i like louisville i like the way that
festival light is laid out
i'd like to go back
um
i'm not sure that's the lineup that
would get me back that's right that's
true but again i mean it is a it is a
wonderful space though they do a very
very nice job with the space i give them
a lot of credit for that yep it's great
that is when you know there aren't
pieces of the interstate falling on you
you know that have i told that story on
this thing
um
the year that i went before you uh i
went with my brother and you know where
river or waterfront park is it's on the
other side of an interstate and you have
to walk under the interstate and there's
even a stage under the interstate and
it was like day
one and i was standing on the united
stand man this thing is really loud
and i just like man
something feels weird about this and i
looked over at my brother i was like do
you does this feel weird yes yeah
about an hour later we're walking back
under the interstate and we get to the
other side of it and bam bam bam
giant pieces of the overpass
fell to the ground within
50 yards of me
i mean had i walked there
90 seconds later
i might have gotten hit with a giant
piece of interstate
i mean that thing was scary
um i don't shut down the festival right
he had just shut down the festival and
you know at the time they got lucky
because
inclement weather was on the forecast
and you know they saw a lightning bolt
and so they cleared everybody out of the
festival for it
and then you know magically we came back
a couple hours later i guess when they
they evaluated the interstate but then
the next year was the worst
torrential storm i've ever been a part
of
in one of these sort of like vulnerable
festival spaces there have been some big
storms at bonnaroo but barry i've never
felt oh it was awful like we felt
running from it felt like
tornado about to happen
sam smith it was sam smith yeah he got
two songs in hello fort castle three two
one good night four castle if you
remember is even worse for him because
he was on stage about two songs in and
somebody had a fireworks um display up
on the bridge that went off that was not
part of his set that everyone thought it
was
and then all of a sudden you and i are
standing by the river and it was a 400
degrees and and i think you said man it
feels pretty good out here right now the
breeze picked up and then then we see
cuellar and all of the asian
entertainment people run yeah
and there goes the stage the stage
literally went that way yeah
it was one of the scariest
moments i've ever
we've never like it's rain there's rain
has been prevalent in monroe for years
and it's rained really hard sometimes
and to a point where like i think i
might just float away this was a
damn near tornado yeah
windshear or a gust nato whatever they
call it that came off the river
yeah it was bad
so if you were to put them in order one
two and three
um from the festivals that we've gone
through today how you ranking them uh i
think you were right i mean uh new
orleans for sure obviously uh
the uh
i mean you tell me i mean for me
personally
um
because yeah that when we were young is
a great lineup but it's not me
sure um
uh yeah yeah yeah new orleans
probably the boston
yeah definitely boston coachella does
nothing for you huh and then coachella
okay and uh
bondry would be probably down down below
yeah i i can't even believe i'm saying
this but riverbend's in there too and
it's because it's close but i really
like it i'm excited i mean if you put
barry doesn't go more than 10 miles so
this is that festival is going to be
great for him uber
yeah
if i can't uber
if i can't over to the festival it
stinks
well i'm just the fact that i'm even
talking why don't you go down why don't
you go down to shaking these this uh
probably going yeah there's a that's a
good one i forgot about that one
has music midtown announce theirs
they're usually much more pop leaning um
they're the kinds that that would give
you like bruno mars no they haven't
announced their lineup yet um that's
another one we're probably holding out
for but that's going to be very very pop
centric
um oh and then governor's ball we're
still waiting for governor's ball so
yeah those are the three that i probably
missed uh anything else this week
anything else you got
uh
no
okay no i'm glad to be
back doing this yeah getting
excited looking forward to the summer
just stay healthy we got to make it
there first
that'll be my luck that's when i'll get
it
but it's absolutely over and nobody has
anything
cut down by the coven it'll be me it
would be like if you got the spanish flu
this year like wait that was how many
decades ago yeah yeah yeah i'm looking
at it barry got polio you got polio yeah
and and spanish flu
yeah like well you know i like shaking
these that's got my guy my morning
jacket krung bin yeah that's a that's
okay that's probably a second for me
yeah yeah i think shaking these for me
is my favorite um you know the low cut
the low cal it helps
i al the only thing too because i don't
know boston callings you know the way
that they've got it set up i i don't
necessarily you know visit boston all
that much i really don't even it's i
know it's near harvard um but i don't
really know the part of town i just i
choose shaky just because i'm so
familiar with the space i haven't been
to boston but i
uh several people i know who have
uh
my son went up there with some buddies
and were able to get a
a room and he was really impressed with
the ability to be able to walk and if
not walk a short cab ride to a bunch of
bars and breweries and and uh
you know
tourists important things to see they
really enjoyed it so i can imagine
that's probably a really cool festival i
mean it's the end of may i'm ready to go
to boston let's do it all right
alex alex let's go to boston we need you
make it happen
uh all right if you don't have anything
else let's uh let's reconvene uh say
next week what do you say ready all
right
what podcast very cool brad steiner talk
to you next week love you bye
[Music]
consequence podcast network